Good evening.
It's me, Markiplier.
Here again joining you on another moonlit night or maybe it's the middle of the day.
But either way, you're cuddled up against your computer or in front of your TV, sipping on your favorite fruity beverage
And what's in that drink? Melons!
More melons than you could possibly count...
More melons than you ever thought could possibly be in the universe because you are Melone in the Dark.
Cue the lightning!
*nothing happens*
Alright, lightning's coming later
But YOU are in for a spook!
Because you may have come to your favorite YouTube channel,
youtube.com/markiplier
...for a daily dose of horror, but--
Got a feeling you could find-
*Walter Melone rambles over Mark...*
Okay...
I like to think--
Uh huh... Okay.
*confused grunt*
*confused and quiet Markimoo*
Ah, sweet big ripe melon
Ok, I understand what you thi- Eughhh huh huh huh! (good lord what is that)
*creeped out Mark noises*
Oh is that me? Oh! I get to be Mr. Malone.
Oh, okay. I don't know what he thinks about melons loving him...
...But I have a funny feeling it's not it's not reciprocated in the way that you think it is when you're eating them.
But alas I shall carry on my- doh.
Oh. Okay.
Oh, yeah! It's very thankful for you devouring them!
La da dee la da daaaa la da dee la da da da daaa
(Mark is a giggly goober)
Oh, this reminds me of uh-
Well maybe they don't like you! Have you ever thought about that?
Have you ever thought of the possibility that you aren't the melon connoisseur that you think you is?
Oh, I wonder why you don't have any friends?
Euughugh!
La da dee la da daaaa la da dee la da da da daaa
(Mark's a goofy giggly goober, yeah!)
Why does this guy remind me of Warfstache?
Ah, I'm so proud of myself.
La da dee
Ah, my extensive book collection on *melons*
Le da dee da da da--
Ah, my ominously squeaking door!
La da oh-
There she is...
The Melon I've been waiting for. The melon taunting me from the windowsill, Oh glistening moonlight!
It's just waiting for me to rend the hard shell and get to the juicy interior...
I didn't mean to make these malones sexu- oh ok.
Ah, good thing my spooky door is working in order.
La da deee la da dee la da dooo
I'm sure this will go wonderfully!
Ahhhh! What is happening? *Mark giggles*
I have no idea.
Oh, God!
You know in a way this reminds me of- what is going on?
I don't know, what is going on?
Oh, oh ok. My head hurts? Ah alright then. Hold space? WOAH!
What the fuck?
What the fuck? My head hurts?
What the fuck? Oh, okay! Alright, I gotta kick the shit out of you! *scream*
Ok, that ain't normal.
Oh, Hi!
Well I don't know if that's true. WABOWSKI
You think you could mess with me?
My melons! I'm betraying my friends!
WA BYEW BOW BOW BOW
*attacking noises*
Ugh, I can't believe I had to do that.
Oh, I guess that's just I prepare all of my midnight snacks. Oh, Okay.
La da deeeee, la da daaa, lee da deeee, da daaaa...
I'm sure these...
...sentient Melon pieces will be...
...extra delicious than my normal variety.
Okay.
(Markimoo freaking out)
(A very uncomfortable Mark)
(Belly Laughs)
Goodbye, Supreme Watermelon! I'll always remember you!
(Mark is losing it)
Is that the end of the god damn game?
Is that it?
Oh, Okay. So we just got to enjoy Wilford Warfstache who was obsessed with melons...
Just beating the shit out of a sentient Melon and for some reason the Supreme Watermelon is only upset that's he's calling him by the wrong name!
And not that he's eating all of his family members and all of his subjects and people. Noo that's- that's normal!
It was made in two weeks for the Watermelon Game Jam! *Mark is DONE xD*
I didn't even know that was a thing!
I just saw "Melone in the Dark", and I was like "Aw, Shit! I gotta play that!" Oh my God. That was amazing.
Ah, Frick dude that was amazing. I am a changed man. What am I going to do with my life now?
I played Melone in the Dark!  The best game ever made.
*reading description*
Oh, man. I've never played that game. Oh, that's so funny though.
Oh, that's so funny, I don't know why it's so funny. His name is Walter too!
Walter Warfstache. Oh, Jeez! Wilford's brother who's even weirder, and you know has a different obsession. God, that's hilarious!
I don't know if you find it as funny, but I'm just like, I'm tickled to death by this game.
I don't know why I love it. So either way that was Melone in the Dark. I know it changed your entire existence.
You're gonna have to go crawl under that blanket you thought was comforting you and watch every corner of the room for the Supreme Watermelon...
...who's stalking you right now.
And if you just so happen to be one of the one percent of people who are eating a watermelon based...
...treat while watching this video...
...then I'm afraid it's too late.
They're already in your house. You can't eat enough of them!
They'll overtake you and then you will be consumed by the watermelon instead of the other way around!
Ok, all right. That's a scary as I can make that so thanks everybody so much for watching. Hope you enjoyed this one...
I actually really did so let me know what you think down the comments below. And as always I will see you in the next video...
Buh-Bye!
Subtitles done by Oakley_14, TFLegendReborn, Some_Dude, and Emvincible :-)
(Rad outro music plays)
Goodnight now ^-^